we could probably change the name of
wired to tooth run and we would still
have enough to write about every month
so Sebastian is was the lead engineer in
the Google self-driving car project
which you've all probably heard about he
also just for laughs at Stanford put his
grad level AI course online and opened
it up to the public a hundred and sixty
thousand students took it they signed up
it from 190 countries it translated into
44 languages and that experiment has led
to Udacity which is a company that that
opens up online education for professors
at various colleges and in addition to
that as the lead of Google's Google X
Department he's involved in all sorts of
secretive whiz-bang projects that we
don't know about and one that we do the
recently announced Google glass which I
don't know if you guys saw this video
but is it will describe it in like
further but it's a new interface that
involves no keyboards or fingers really
anyway so Sebastian thank you very much
for joining us it's very thanks for
inviting me it's very exciting to have
you so let's start we've got sort of a
tripartite discussion here we'll start
by talking about the self-driving car
tell me a little bit about where the
idea for this project came from you know
what inspired you to build a car that
drives itself I came to Stanford in 2003
and I was kind of out of work at the
time I had finished my research work on
email and I wonder something new and
it's DARPA Grand Challenge came along
where the US government had said if
someone can build a robotic car they can
drive it 700 miles through the desert
you're going to give that person on the
team a million bucks so I figure there's
an easy thing to do that my colleague
Steve with it and I went to the first
grand challenge and watched it and the
cars would go a mile and then crash and
burn up in flames
anyone went with seven miles so I got to
this point where my testosterone kicked
in and I felt I could do better than
that I can do eight miles or nine miles
so I put together a team not knowing
what I'm doing and I spend next year on
the front seat of a car with writing
computer code at the same time driving
the car and so on until it finally I
guess one the darpa grand challenge I
guess it did yes and that was that was
one year later right the 2000-2005 you
actually completed yep the whole course
yep so what changed between what warns
people doing in 2004 I mean that's such
a huge Delta what weren't people doing
in 2004 that you knew how my god it was
amazingly embarrassing every time you
look back at technology and the back of
the past it looks just really
embarrassing myself included at the time
very simplified speaking people had used
GPS to guide these cars around right but
gps has a certain amount of error is
like gonna 2030 feet at times and there
was too much error to keep the car on an
centered on narrow lane and from
2004-2005 what people we didn't
reinvented was the ability for the car
to see the lane and use more reactive
visual feedback to keep the car on the
lane so as a result they actually stayed
on the lane didn't drive off the lane
and in driving that makes all the
difference and these are things like
that's a good tip yep keep that in mind
that's right you're so right so and this
is using things like radar and lidar and
sensor size me for sine amras and got it
so at some point you were sold Stanford
at this point correct and at some point
you does de google approached you at
that point yes I've been working at
Google the kind of part time I helped
build up Street View and other things
and I helped build up google has an
internal mapping department that builds
maps so I was involved in dead and at
some point it became clear that there's
a much bigger vision here than just
chasing cars to the desert which has to
do with all the civilization right so
all of us drive cars all the time it's
the second biggest expense in the
American households transportation cars
kill lots of people cause lots of
excellence people driving cars cause
accidents in this country's about 35,000
a year that died in the war is about a
million people and I looked at this in
felt it shouldn't be that way I mean
it's the the number one
for young people we should make a stress
safe and and the grand challenge was
like the very first moment where we
could look at safe driving because now
we moved the driving responsibility from
possibly flawed people to at the time
certainly flawed computers but at least
the chance was there to make this
computer is really really good moving it
from Stanford to Google was kind of a
no-brainer and the reason is for one
this is a big computer undertaking it's
really about the data about the machine
intelligence it's not as much about the
hardware itself the car itself so we
needed a partner an entity that really
understands data and and what better
place is there in this at this moment
and Google to understand large data
centers information processing and so on
the second thing that happened with
Google is if you're a college professor
you do you do fantastic small research
project with the students and you raise
half a million dollars here for for
research and having us there it's really
hard to get the budget together to put a
vast engineering team in place and
something like this require a
significant engineering so going to
someone who has deeper pockets than the
National Science Foundation and our prom
really helped us in in turn these into
reality right and I remember learning
about the self-driving car in a I think
it was a front page story in The Times
obviously read the New York Times a lot
and it was just this sort of shocking
story like all of a sudden oh hey google
has these self-driving cars and they've
been driving them for tens of thousands
of miles that any human involvement and
it was one of those moments where you
know one of those Wow the futures really
here moans how did that how did that
come about we talked a little bit about
this before this sort of unveiling was
that planned or it was half planned John
Markoff the the person four attempts who
broke the news is actually very skilled
and wonderful investigative journalist
we've been driving these cars around on
public streets four hundred forty
thousand miles and we carefully
monitored every single block poster came
out and of course ever plenty pictures
taking on Facebook and Twitter and and
so on of these cars and people have all
kinds of theories I thought it was like
weather stations this is this ongoing
theory that we doing energy regeneration
with this device on the roof right if
you think about this cool
basic physics of driving something along
to generate energy from driving along
with just not a particularly smart way
yeah but there was more popular than
your policies would actually be a
self-driving car and eventually it
became clear so drawn contacted us at
Google we invited him over for a test
drive at the time we had a system was
actually fairly reliable and and and he
was very impressed so he talked about
goose bumps as one of the the physical
reaction to being driven by a car so you
got really excited and that was really a
wonderful moment for us as a team
because it really meant that we could
not be open about it the world knew
about it and the reception in general
was just very very positive as well if
let's share some of that we have a video
i believe i think it's cued up of the
self-driving car in action can we get
that on the big screen
hey how are you I just drank whiskey
auto driving your go where we go look ma
no hands you should know i am aware no
hands no I love it so we're here at the
stop sign cars using radars and laser to
to check and make sure there's nothing
coming in a way but fight myself old
habits die hard and they don't die
anybody up for a taco yeah yeah what do
you want it what do you wanna do today
Steve I'm I'm all talking all right well
let's go get a talk with the drive-thru
and we're turning into the parking go
creep along here does anybody have in
mind I've got my know I've got my wallet
right here and roll down your window in
order burrito yeah okay very well how
are you today this is some of the best
driving I've ever done ninety-five
percent of my vision is is gone I'm well
past legally blind
you lose your timing in life everything
takes you much longer there are some
places that you cannot go there are some
things that you really cannot do where
this would change my life is to give me
the independence and the flexibility to
go the places I both want to go and need
to go when I need to do those things
right it's been nice you know the hit
fits good night
it's really it's really moving it's hard
not to get choked up and it's also hard
not to get hungry for tacos but so talk
to me about what where we are in the
state of this development how long you
know what are some of the challenges a
technological challenges social
challenges what has to happen for these
things to come so by far the biggest
challenge remains to be technological so
we're at the point right now where we
can drive a couple of miles have a
thousand miles without a person taking
over but we can't drive a couple of
million miles without a person taking
over and that's all the difference so
right now they're not as safe as a human
driver would be having said this I I
took the car to tahoe last weekend and
it drove flawlessly and I was sitting
behind it and I my train safety driver
so I went through special driving school
for this sitting there doing nothing for
hours on end and my wife said the car
was a better driver than me but I ended
up being much more relaxed than a normal
am and I drive these long distance
drives and it's really a
transformational experience so we are
working really hard various states have
actually are passing legislation right
now to enable this technology Nevada has
led the charter year by putting
legislation and regulation in place that
regulates all of this Florida is has
passed a bill and raise other states are
following so I think the social
acceptance right now and the political
acceptance is actually very high so it
works is it legal to do what you did is
it legal to drive this in California I
assume it must be well certainly wasn't
illegal for me the law is mostly what
things you're not supposed to do right
we made it so that we always had a
safety driver behind the wheel and the
safety engineer on the side and they
were in control of the car so we drove
it more like in it and the advanced
cruise control so I don't aware of any
loss to be broken okay seems nobody else
be aware of this right okay good and
we've got a lot to we saw I'm gonna have
to start talking more quickly because we
have so much to get through but I want
to talk a little bit about this idea
that the there's you have a higher
standard for a computer-driven car
essentially than a human driven car like
humans are not particularly good at
driving cars
but if a self-driving car had the same
safety record as humans nobody would
accept it I completely agree so what's
what's the standard that self-driving
cars is there a ratio that you're that
you're reaching towards there's no ratio
I think it's going to be a process and I
hope that the combo of a human driver
and robotic technology will will make
the entire combo significantly safer
while not just handing over the control
to the car itself and that's suddenly
we're working out right now to
understand how to best do this at some
level we have the words most amazing
technology it's really transformational
to be in it the other hand we don't have
something we can sell because it's
really too weak it crashes it would
crash too often if we sold it so it's
going to be the our homework exercise
for the next couple of months and years
to figure out how to best in all these
things together so we get a product that
just video works I wish to get to the
point where there's no accidents caused
by our car great I mean I have a lot
more to talk about we've got 12 minutes
to talk about the future of higher
education and also Google's approach to
innovation so let's move along did 59
yes you're right and and Sebastian again
we're not gonna be able to open this up
for questions but Sebastian will be
around for lunch so again get him so
okay let's move on to Udacity it talk to
me about the decision to open up your
classroom in the first place where did
this come from so the decision came from
watching Falcon talk at Ted anybody here
saw South camps bigoted so I said last
year's conference is is one of my heroes
and and he spoke about how his videos
that he made for his nieces but be
watched by hundreds of thousands of kids
around the nation and I felt embarrassed
that my class at Stanford was watched by
200 well selected Stanford students so
very spontaneously even without telling
steph OV we basically put this thing
online and in no time guts what turned
out to be in the end handed 60,000
students sign up and then we taught it
and I was extremely skeptical I felt
that the classroom experience is really
essential and small classes are bigger
than large classes and if you go to
160,000 you can't do anything but to my
surprise
23,000 made all the way to the end which
is a large number in my opinion it was
and this is this is a graduate level
course graduate level artificial
intelligence class I mean there's not
that many people caring about a iodine
off yeah it was certainly more than all
other professors taught in combination
the other thing was really surprising is
that of the 200 students in my stanford
class 170 didn't show up to class
anymore they watched me on video they
could remind me they could watch me at
any time there weren't embarrassed to
see the same thing twice and they
actually many of them reported in
intimacy let me see anybody here took
any class of Udacity so far no not yet
okay so I keep running into random
people doing this it turns out the
digital medium for education is a lot of
potential that is currently unharness
the way most people think about online
education is you you videotape the
professor and you take that taping that
video and put it online that's just the
same as all our film was about
videotaping a stage and putting that on
line which was truly early film was like
that but in film we now have
cinematography we have amazing effects
in online teaching what we end up doing
making it super interactive more like a
video game where we had lots of quizzes
and ways to people can do programs
software development inside inside the
video medium and I think there's an
opportunity here to go much broader than
just what's been known right now well
and it sounds like students were sort of
self-organizing into study groups and
you know it sort of took on a life of
its own can you can you talk about that
little bit too yes there was a lot of
stuff happening around it professors
organized classes around it there was a
counter class called artistic
intelligence students gathered and ended
the various kind of like physical
sessions there was a facebook group
various G+ groups and so on so this
entire things put a lot of activity in
the world and how do you grade 200 like
the projects from 200,000 to but the
real question is how do you recover from
a grating mistake that's much harder
because you get 20,000 emails saying
professor you got this wrong we did all
the grading automatically so we put a
multiple choice questions we put up in
America questions and now we even have
gradable software with people write
software and the little robot that we
built goes out and grades automatically
well that's not
perfect I mean I wish I could really sit
with people my don't want to do this
with Hannah 60,000 people but but it's
actually much more systematic or than
most college grading with TAS to
integrate somewhat randomly and we
graded the Stanford students the same
way we graded our online students for
most parts so we could compare them and
so on I was really interesting and you
mentioned that this opened up some ideas
of education for you that you know one
of your students parents was criticizing
you for not letting them retake a test
because it was you were it was giving
them one chance to succeed can you can
you talk I I learned a lot about me as
an educator as a lifelong educator and
that is for example grades I used grades
a lot to give strong students a positive
feedback and weaker students negative
feedback and if you look at most
students experience in school or in the
university it's usually negative usually
they work really hard and they get a be
alright and then the next class they
move on to they might not have the
necessary prerequisites of other than
doing it again which is kind of
embarrassing they move to the next class
and math that's really fatal if you
don't know what's happening and you got
to see then you have no chance to get an
A in the next class so the entire
experience becomes negative so rather
than grading which is what it in the
beginning and I hit my harsh grating
like head on it's the sample professor I
switch it entirely to saying well why
don't you get everybody to an a-plus
level and if it takes students longer
they should just try more and if they
can eventually solve this really hard
problems like the Stanford level greater
problems then just give them extra time
and they can get an a-plus so my
inspiration right now is to get every
student in a plus but still make them
work as hard as necessary to get to the
skill level that's great so from here
you launched a whole company around this
idea Udacity talk to me about what you'd
acid is so you'd ask the D aspires to be
a university and that might be a little
bit pretentious but but we really want
to do is enter and higher education and
the reason why I believe this makes
sense is if you look today today the
educational field is organized the way
stage play was organized a hundred years
ago before we had a medium that provided
scale and in the movie industry called
celluloid in our case called digital we
have tens of thousands of professors
that teach the same stuff year in year
out like it makes no sense to me if I
professor teacher classes here they
would have exactly the same lectures
next year again right it makes no sense
to me that the professor and
class teachers the classes university a
university / teaches the exact same
class because of this I think the
current education experiences very
mediocre not every professor is great I
think there's a lot of professors that
do a fine job but not as good as it
could be in my own education I had many
many professors is anybody know what the
city I really was but they taught
because their tenure at my local college
bye-bye going digital we can bring the
scale so if we if you have a hundred
thousand students per class what we can
do now is we can make a really really
great class we can invest the money to
make the experience really great we can
tailor it to the individual people so
they can match the speed of those people
and we can have a community around it
that interacts maybe a tens of thousands
of students that vision to me is really
profound it also deals with one of the
biggest problems in the United States
higher education system which is cost
student loans is the number one dead
right now for the American people it's
surpassed the trillion dollars it's more
than the housing dead or the credit card
dead and the college costs have been
going up by constant six percent per
year whereas the return of investments
as you gone down the ability to get a
great job with an education has actually
gone down so we are clearly in a bubble
and clearly it'll burst so I hope that a
university like Udacity can come to help
save it by providing in this case we
actually making everything available for
free all right so you can get an entire
education for free right now in computer
science online at Udacity you need no
don't need a college town at all I
really hope to use the scalability of
digital media to bring back to people
great high quality education so and are
these courses accredited right now they
are not accredited and you're working on
it got it and absolutely and is this
scalable to for instance the public high
school system this model look I think
the the word is still out there i'm
extremely excited not just Udacity but
many other companies are playing with
ideas and experimenting in this space
certainly salman khan who is one of my
heroes has been leading the nation in
doing this and i think we should do this
we should be innovative in the education
space if you think about what's having
education today it's not that dissimilar
from the way it was organized a thousand
years ago the lecture so the primary
means of education in it
in colleges which was exactly what
happened when the first University
started in melania in Italy a thousand
years ago it's amazing how much the
education system has been robust to an
innovation where everybody else is
falling through the media and nas's it's
becoming more efficient classes are just
the same way there were 10 20 50 hundred
years ago so for me I'm super excited to
see many different companies in that
space playing with ideas we should be
open-minded about it we should try these
things out I have a hunch that where we
come out with will be significantly more
economical education will be much much
cheaper like like orders of magnitude
cheaper right now our costs per students
per class like a dollar as opposed to
$1,500 which is what good college
discharge and as a result we can reach
people and all trades in the life in
continuing education around the world
everywhere now is is anything lost by
the you know part of being a college
student is being around other college
students and having those sort of social
connections when you remove the physical
you know cohabitation of it for instance
is something lost on that how do you how
do you keep that in all these viet
parties and finding your living mate and
so on yes yes yeah yeah so it's nothing
is perfect so if you you should never
think of a new invention like digital
media in education as a complete
replacement of the old like there's
there's beauty and physical presence and
and that is certainly being affected
having said this in this day and age
many of the college kids and high school
kids hang out more on social chat rooms
and media and Facebook and G+ then they
hang out in the physical world together
there's profound changes in society I
think we're going to emerge with a
different model in the end we're going
to merge for the model where we don't
carve out four years in your life as
your educational phase and then say from
there on you don't need any more
education you can just do a job you're
going to come with the model with maybe
the initial indications shorter but as
you do your job you can stay educated
really easily you take your tablet with
you you learn on the bus in these short
moments of your day where you have a
minute to spare and then learning
becomes a lifelong endeavor and that's
going to be very different quality and
agree it's going to be harder for dating
and finding the right boy or girl that
we're not going to replace that easily
but so be it right
alright so great so you I know you've
got a four-year-old son I have a
three-year-old son and so now we've
taken care of their drivers license and
we've taken care of their college debt
which is then thanks good my hat goes
off to you thank you for I'm just not
going to save anything now that's great
all right so let's move on to Google X
let's it's a shame that we don't have
the video with us but maybe you can
describe maybe you can paint a picture
for us of have people see in this video
of the google glass project I see some
yeses and some nose so for the for the
nose so we couldn't describe it for us
so Google X in a single sentence this is
my ambition and not just my mission
Larry and sergey's ambition to really do
moonshot type projects and not just
shooting for the moon but bring the moon
back to earth and launch products the
most recent one we've announced has been
google glass or a third project avidat
indoor maps and self-driving cars before
and it was in the beginning this crazy
thing like how can you bring a computer
out of your pocket to a place where you
have it with you all the time and if you
looked around at the time there was
something called heads-up displays a
very kind of technical term and they're
usually like glass block so if you flop
into your eyes and you wouldn't see much
other than these things and they were
crunched on your nose because they
really heavy and it will project us
inside and people talked about augmented
reality how cool that over be so we
started saying well that's kind of nice
but not what I want in my life how can
we think about a technology more
liberating Peter technology how can we
make what Jack Dorsey calls technology
that goes away that you don't see and
then we realize we really bothered by
our phones I am personally if I take
down my front pocket to to take a
picture you have to take it out I have
to unlock it f2 right side app fire up
the camera app take finally take the
picture it takes me 40 seconds or sort
of do this why can't let us take a
picture with the basically right on my
eye I don't have the camera with me that
other people can see through my eyes as
I go go to the world so we came up with
this concept of building a super
lightweight computer that is with you in
your face all the time it's called
google glass it's a project so far it's
not a product and what it provides us is
a display that you can see information
it has a camera so it's really easy to
a picture I did this on Charlie Rose or
just doing doing my interview I took a
picture of him I think I'd be the first
to ever insult him by taking a picture
of him life doing the show and it has
also an es free components so you can
make phone calls without having anything
new year using a speaker that touches
your head which is turns out to be a
really magical experience when you try
it out so the idea is why we all want to
be connected we want to be in the in the
information flow we've also wanna be in
the physical world whenever hands-free
our eyes free yes free google glasses
our best shot right now at Google to
achieve that and you know I suppose the
the devil's advocate take on this is we
were already sort of barrage by various
digital media and we can't get away from
it and how you know why do we need a
constant overlay of digital media in our
inner vision I think that is a really a
legitimate concern and if I looked at
the feedback we got when we got to the
public and listen to people i think
distraction has been the number one
concern so we've been v looking into can
we make this device there for you when
you want it and need it but not distract
you and in our prototypes we changed a
whole bunch of things so for example in
addition to being a camera we also use
it for communication so if someone texts
me the message actually pops up I can
read it we now move to a point where
when I'm in a situation where I just
don't want to be distracted I have the
freedom to just let go so that I can can
live my life to the fullest and if I'm
in my own and wishing to go through the
information that I may be missed last 10
15 20 minutes I can go back and it's an
ongoing development effort I really love
to hear from people they reasonably went
public by the way is for 110 in public
but also we want to get feedback from
everybody who might be our future
customers to really understand what are
your concerns for your aspirations what
do you associate with the device like
this was your creativity and and I think
this this freshman concern really came
up and and we really are looking very
systematic into this right now I'm going
to just one last question we're already
a little over time so the theme here is
disruption how do you create a
department whose job is to land well
moon every year i can tell you i can
tell you every single employee
so that I have every report that I have
my very first conversation is rule
number one disobey your manager don't
listen to your manager and they all
caliber you like we're all getting
Sebastian I came to Google to work with
you how are you telling me this I don't
believe you and a year later they come
back to me every sequence is now I
understand so I think a lot of it is
about this is the age of disruption
there's an amazing number of eternities
right now and in the execution of
disruption many especially large
companies have a hard time doing this
because it seems like everybody has an
opinion right and and we make it really
hard for people to to get out of this
this aura of opinions and directions if
you have a manager as a manager as a VP
as SVP & CEO your whole stack of
opinions but I try to do as a shield my
teams from those opinions I really try
to get people maximum operating space
give him a vision that I believe in and
that they believe in and it takes a lot
of work to get a good vision like Google
glass and then just do the thing and
then they come back a year later and
something amazing usually emerges it's
great well thank you so much Sebastian
this was great thank you